sí efectivamente la guerra en Ucrania
es una situación sumamente preocupante y
dramática para los millones de
ucranianos que han tenido que salir pero
también para toda la región es la
primera vez en mucho tiempo que una
potencia como Rusia ataca eh agrede
invade eh de forma
tan violenta un país y eso ha causado
una gran estabilización en la región a
su vez hay otros conflictos un poco más
olvidados numerosos por ejemplo el de
yemen donde se tiene más de doscientos
mil personas que que han muerto o la
situación en mi alma en Asia o también
la reciente situación de conflicto en el
tigre en Etiopía
volviendo la mirada a la región
latinoamericana preocupa la situación
política en varios países como El
Salvador o Nicaragua Cómo ha
evolucionado la situación en la región
en estos últimos años
Sí hay un fenómeno muy preocupante
de deterioro de la democracia y en
particular por ejemplo en el caso de
Nicaragua donde se entró a una dictadura
con una violencia represiva
absolutamente inaceptable
hay más de trescientas personas que han
sido asesinados ejecutados
perjudicialmente en este momento
hay doscientos veintiuno presos
políticos y sigue el régimen de Ortega
Murillo deteniendo a personas porque son
de la oposición Porque eran periodistas
y inclusive ahora están definiendo a los
familiares porque no encuentran a esas
personas y y un siete el espacio
encerrado pues mil organizaciones
ocupar mentales Pero además esta
situación hay un fenómeno en particular
en
de deterioro o Guatemala Diamante y la
gran afectación a la independencia de la
justicia donde han tenido que huir
Fiscales que estaban luchando y
denunciando la corrupción en El Salvador
con con la actitud del presidente bukele
Entonces sí en la región ocupa mucho
esta este defecto Ahora hay que decir
que también hay algunas
situaciones de Esperanza no